it's great to welcome back to the
program today rachel bittikoffer who's
an election forecaster and analyst host
of the podcast the election whisperer as
well as the founder of strike pack
rachel always great having you on thank
you
yeah and david i have to update my bio
because i left strike pack in april and
uh do independent work now okay well we
will make that change we will update
that so listen um you know usually
there's this conventional wisdom uh when
democrats run on issues like abortion
and gun safety it doesn't do anything to
get democrats out to vote but it angers
republicans it gets republicans out to
vote against democrats and yet when we
look at the polling over the last two
months it seems as though
talking about roe v wade and talking
about republican inaction on gun safety
is actually activating the democratic
base and all of a sudden the numbers are
not looking as bad for democrats as they
typically would in the first midterm
after winning the white house is that an
accurate assessment or am i missing
something
no i mean no i'm gonna say it's not i'm
gonna say there's some things that i
would push back on there okay
i mean there is a perception right and
i'm sure the progressive left is used to
hearing this um excuse as to why
cultural issues have not been focused on
in democratic campaigns this idea of
cross-mobilization right like you're
trying to mobilize your own base but all
you do is motivate the other one that
there's absolutely no data to support
that assertion and i have tried to prove
it quantitatively before
so it's really important for people to
understand that you know if the
republican party has been fed that kind
of messaging for years and it doesn't
necessarily motivate us what motivates
us is a fear or threat catalyst so when
we look at what happened in kansas last
night i started talking once the memo
leaked for the row evisceration so if
that if that memo comes to fruition and
they um you know repeal row and all
these abortion laws go into effect their
gop is going to be able to ban you know
total abortion ban in the places they
have trifecta control what we're going
to see is is a
potentially
um something so strong and so
catastrophic in the body politic that
you could see a momentum change from the
fundamental midterms
of midterm fundamentals that are against
the in party right and so what we saw
initially was spontaneous
protest pop up everywhere that was a
really good data sign something similar
to what we saw in 2017 and 2018 when we
saw the trump effect coming and then of
course kansas is our first election
since then it was of course heavily
focused on it was the only thing on the
ballot so it's really important for
people to understand that abortion um
salience from from rho is a product in
kansas is a product of it being heavily
focused on so it's really important
people focus on it it's not gonna be
some residual effect that they can tap
into without trying to harvest it and uh
it's based on negative partisanship
people are
people are active our side especially
when they feel threatened and when biden
got elected a lot of people rolled back
that fear and now it's back
and so when you look at the 538 senate
forecast for example which is kind of
ticked up and up where now it says
democrats have a 57 percent chance of
holding the senate that is the result of
exactly the factors you just listed
yes these are quantitative metrics so i
put out i mean if you follow me
regularly on twitter and i recommend you
do and just read my thread because it's
really where i do most of my my my
analysis these days because of time
limitations um you'll see that i start
talking about midterm effects the
midterm in the four-year presidential
term always hurts the in party because
the in party is the one getting all the
bad headlines right especially faces a
dishonest opposition right and so um
when we talked about the midterm effect
i said listen there's been two
interruptions in the midterm effect both
of those were times when the national
conversation got disrupted uh and the
most recent was 2002 with bush because
keep in mind he was ceded into the
presidency of a very very large
controversy and was not popular until 9
11. right and so that midterm would have
been bruising for republicans and
instead they gained seat so i started
talking about you know look we're gonna
we can't just bear our heads in the
stand and pretend that fundamentals
don't matter so let's try to move the
mechanisms that move the midterm effect
and one you know those are that's about
national referendum on the republican
party and we really are starting to see
the system um you know resonate those
changes in data so in 2002 like you say
at the time of the midterms the
president had a high approval rating as
a result of 9 11. right now joe biden
has a very low approval rating i went
back and looked it looks like you have
to go back to 19 1946 or 45 when a
president at this point in their first
term had this low in approval rating it
was truman is the expectation that with
biden at 37 percent that that will
specifically hurt democrats in november
or have the have the two become
disaggregated to some degree now versus
20 years ago
oh absolutely disaggregated and every
time somebody tells me oh i did a
cross-time analysis where it was like
this in 1993 and i'm like yeah dude
because polarization is not it's not
some buzzword it's a quantifiable
behavioral characteristic that manifest
in behavior across elites the mass
public politicians media system and it
has caused it has really um disrupted
the ability to look back in time and
make comparisons because let me explain
why biden's approval rating is so low
and also lower than donald's trump
donald trump's when any objective
assessment would definitely tell you
which of these two presidencies were
more controversial turbulent um and the
reason is because hyperpartisanship and
polarization is asymmetrical it affects
the right side of the isle war which is
why the republican party is having a
flirt with fascism moment here and one
of the ways that it manifests is tribal
allegiance so when whatever happened
with donald trump no matter how bad the
headline was that week his approval
rating was stagnant it was a flat line
that should never happen in a healthy
democracy okay
and once you started to see in elastic
presidential approval you start to
realize okay i'm measuring latent
partisanship in the electorate and not
actual objectivity so what you see with
biden and why he's worse than trump guys
you're gonna love this is because
progressive democrats are willing to
tell pollsters that they're dissatisfied
with what the administration's been able
to get done so you actually see an 80 20
partisan splinter approval for democrats
versus what you might see in 90 95
10 for donald trump
if uh so
i don't really make economic predictions
but just in taking a look at different
indicators it seems to me that next
tuesday we're going to get an inflation
number for july that's significantly
lower than that from june there's going
to be the ability for democrats to
accurately talk about the economy is
looking better as we get into november
with the three months that remain
between now and the midterm elections is
there an opportunity to get back to
talking about the economy uh will it
will it make a difference is that what
democrats should do if indeed inflation
starts declining and the the numbers
look better
i mean here's the thing is and i talk
about this a lot there's three issues
that are going to dominate the midterm
in terms of the availability of issues
to affect things which is mostly low
coalitional turnout but also conversion
pool that 10 or 15 percent of pure
independence who can be
affected are going to be affected by the
national atmosphere
and so what i've said with democrats is
you know the republican party voted on
mass against the one piece of
legislation we were able to put on the
floor to lower inflation so you wedge
that and you just hit them over the head
with one theme they had a chance to act
against inflation and what did they do
they put politics over you
is there any senate race right now that
you consider to be
any kind of bellwether in a sense or are
the things that are happening for
example in the walker warnock race in
georgia completely unrelated to what's
happening with like oz fetterman in
pennsylvania or like what are you what
are you looking at in terms of specific
races
well i mean we've got a really
interesting scenario when it look when
we think about oz and uh walker i mean
both of these are are really
tremendously weak candidates
so that i mean
i think that pennsylvania was always
going to be a toss-up and maybe
advantage fetterman against a normal
nominee and then luckily it's not it's a
product of a bad nominee and also what
the fetterman campaign is doing with the
clay that they have okay so getting a
bad nominee is one thing getting making
use of that and
and using it as an effective branding
weapon against your opponent is another
okay and so the reason we're seeing such
good numbers out of georgia and
pennsylvania right now is because both
of those campaigns went aggressive
especially the outside groups too um in
the case of georgia on branding the
opponent and and and creating
a disqualified you know disqualification
effect and that's really what democrats
have to do in a minute in this midterm
so normally you know you might look at
republicans and be like okay you know
inflation's high they're not offering
you inflation um solutions right they
run against one thing and that is
democrats are socialists that want to
turn your men child into women and we're
going to save you from there right so
like when we think about
so anything about inflation and what
that party is offering they are so weak
on the economy that it should not be
hard at all for democrats to disqualify
change and so when i talk about
messaging on economy on a dump on
democracy rights freedom and abortion
which all tie in i'm really talking
about messaging that is focused squarely
on the republican party making sure
people understand what that party looks
like today how crazy and dangerous it is
for them personally the asymmetrical uh
aspect to this between republicans and
democrats
seems almost like scarily present in the
walker versus warnock race because i
mean walker can barely explain a single
position like he can't he the guy can
barely speak and we've talked before
like is it cte from football is it
there's all these different things okay
you can speculate about he can't
articulate his position on any issue and
yet he's only losing by like eight or
nine points or something like that which
just shows the completely different
standards that republicans have for who
they're willing to vote for
oh exactly yeah no i mean here's the
thing once you get late in partnership
so like no one's paying attention to
this stuff right now that we know about
so you know once once the campaign
actually gets going in september and the
like the rest of the marginal voting
population gets brought into the
conversation
actually what you're going to see is a
vote share probably will go up not down
dude and that's because a lot i mean it
is you know they voted for a obvious
child predator in alabama 90 10 in that
special election that doug jones won and
doug jones won it okay but he did not
win it because republicans rejected a
child predator he won it because of a
cert of massive turnout and black vote
and black voter turnout and um you know
a little bit of conversion pull pull off
that was a kind of like a perfect storm
that allowed him to do it but if they'll
put
him in the senate this man that that had
a new york you know 11 accusations of
being a child predator they'll put
anybody in there doesn't matter because
what their job what they care about now
is seizing power and then using it to
crush us so let's talk a little bit in
the last few minutes we have about the
way in which 22 may impact 24
specifically for trump and biden there's
the idea that depending on how trump
endorsed and maga people do in 2022 it
will impact whether trump tries to be
the nominee in 24. another perspective
is trump's going to try because he
thinks it'll keep him out of legal
trouble so there's like the trump side
of things on the biden side
i've never really felt biden it planned
to run for re-election in 24 i just
don't think he's doing it i don't think
he ever really wanted to
jen saki from the get-go would say joe
biden intends to run and then when
kamala harris said he's running the next
day she walked it back and said his
intention is so i just i just don't
think he's running for reelection
how does what happens in 22
impact the potential candidacies of
either of those two people
i mean i can tell you these two
elections roll together guys if we do
not show up in large numbers and defend
democracy here in 22 then we stand
potentially lose the governorships no
matter how bad the candidates are in
michigan and pennsylvania if we were to
lose either one of those then we'd lose
the blue wall the big three and that's
the big three that hits 270. so we can
lose georgia we can lose arizona okay
and we may well lose those to fascist
republicans if people vote but at the
end of the day like we cannot lose
michigan and pennsylvania or we do not
have a guarantee of a free and fair
election
at all for 2024 i mean imagine a newly
minted republican governor of michigan
do you think they're going to be on the
side of democracy or outside fascism
right i'm going with fascism
what do you think about the biden 24
thing have you given any thought to it
you know here's what i would say is if
he doesn't plan on running he doesn't
act like that to me he's as cautious as
any traditional first-term president
which is you know if i had to offer a
criticism
to the administration it would be that
this is this is a moment for churchill
not chamberlain we need winston
churchill in the in
posturally in that leadership position
we need somebody to speak very frankly
headed into 22 about the stakes of this
election what's on the ballot across
these 50 states and and uh state
legislatures and and federal house
elections because you know at the end of
the day he's got the bully pulpit nobody
else has that bully pulled it and i
honestly think
whether his intends to run or not that
would serve him best politically too but
right now you don't question that his
plan is to run for reelection
i i just don't bother speculating about
stuff like that right now david i'm
really focused on trying to keep
democracy from falling into a fascist
pit fair that's a good that's a good
thing to focus on i would say actually
uh we've been speaking speaking with
rachel bittikoffer election forecaster
analyst the podcast is the election
whisperer rachel always a pleasure
having you on thank you
yeah thank you so much and if you don't
mind my plug my new book that is going
to be coming out 2023 by crown and it's
called him hit him where it hurts how to
be how to save democracy by beating
republicans at their own game well i'm
sure we'll have you on to talk about it
when the book is out yeah for sure thank
you rachel